prix de saint-egrève dans l'isère
bonjour garcimore merkel voulait pas et
là j'ai mis un petit tour ici oui vous
avez bien mais j'ai deux ficelles pour
les regarder
je voulais alors les garderies de
ficelle et obtenu richard l'a alors s'il
vous plaît vous allez à souffler sophie
plus fort
bravo c'est vraiment me réserver la
primeur
non mais qu il est tellement cool oui
j'ai quelques cartes ici j'en avais je
vous ai vue de faire de loin tout à
l'heure mais jusqu'à demander de lui
répéter alors on a 1 2 3 4 5 4 mais
celle là qui a au million seller wadi
pic alors j'ai pris aussi la quête que
vous voulez de celle là oui lesquelles
des quatre qui l'entourent je n'ai pas
le droit de choisir sa non puisqu'il est
également parce que ce que je vais vous
dire laquelle dû soigner alors choisi ça
le web des cadeaux oui mais pourquoi pas
comme ça les gars veulent puisqu'ils y
bat il mâche et heureusement on souffle
il est 8 des carreaux que vous avez
choisi il la cie menaient à oui c'est
vraiment assez extraordinaire vous
voulez enfin une autre france agit sur
notre peau des pics 1 me pour sa cellule
sous le nom c'est bien moi ça m'est égal
3 d'epic
il est rentré dedans sans les côtés ah
oui depuis qu'il est là mais comment
vous faites ça voulait prendre expliqué
un jour en direct quand même parce
qu'après vous savez une fois qu'ils les
auront call in explique rien du tout moi
je ne sais rien jamais ne même expliqué
mais notre you vient d'ouvrir le champ
de la les bébés de tak tak hyper très
écouté ça peut attendre c'est vraiment
garcimore là je vais vous dire une chose
je ne le blâme de rien alors pour jouer
j'ai plus tard qu'il ya deux mois non
mais franchement c'est gentil vous
l'apprenez elle et ses enfants et les
petits-enfants et puis voilà bouche non
franchement écouter non comment voulez
vous être sérieux tranquille sans ce
plateau
on vous met des souris partout non alors
selon sérieux gérard maintenant
commençons à jouer nous avons des sommes
importantes qui sont en jeu
[Musique]